[Musique]
le conseil départemental du haut rhin a
élu vendredi dernier son nouveau
président sans surprise
rémy vite premier vice président a été
désigné par l'assemblée à l'unanimité
l'élu du canton de masevaux remplace
brigitte klinkert parti au gouvernement
il présidera l'assemblée départementale
jusqu'au 31 décembre date de la création
de la collectivité européenne d'alsace
on est toujours fier de président d'une
collectivité je crois mais c'est vrai
que l'idéal aurait été que madame la
ministre reste président du conseil
départemental mais bon le bonheur le
bonheur et est aussi laquelle qu'elles
puissent nous représenter au
gouvernement et je crois que
cette promotion nous fait plaisir
j'essayerai en tant que premier
vice-président d'assumer comme j'ai
toujours fait à ses côtés j'essayais de
l'assumer maintenant tant que président
mais comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
je elle sera à côté de moi je souhaite
qu'elle soit à mes côtés pour qu'elle
puisse m'accompagner dans ses dents ces
derniers quatre mois qui seront pas de
tout repos
pas de grande révolution politique
attendue dans le haut rhin pour les
quatre derniers mois de l'assemblée le
nouveau président poursuivra l'action
entamée aux côtés de brigitte klinkert à
122 jours de la mise en place de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace
l'exécutif haut rhinois sera d'ailleurs
particulièrement focalisé sur cette
dernière
ces quatre mois vont être dense vont
être je dirais compliqué sans doute
beaucoup de négociations en vue puisque
je ne vous le cache pas nous sommes dans
la dernière ligne droite de la nouvelle
collecte ils étaient européennes
d'alsace et avec nos amis bas rhinois
nous aurons à mener à affiner et à
construire ce programme politique ou ce
projet politique qui est acquis est à
finaliser maintenant sur ces quatre mois
qui viennent ça chez les filles avec
confiance et sérénité au titre des
points encore en négociation le siège de
la future collectivité une question
épineuse que les élus locaux ou préféré
réserver pour la dernière ligne droite
ça fait partie des choses encore à
discuter à négocier à échanger pour pour
dire plus clairement le siège n'est pas
défini est-ce qu'on va vers un siège
provisoire ou pas après c'est à la scea
aussi de valider le siège définitivement
après tout ça sont des aspects qui font
partie d'un ordre du jour assez chargé
dix pendant ces quatre mois comme vous
du côté des administrations le nouveau
président la sueur agents au rhino et
bas rhinois sont d'ores et déjà prêts
pour la fusion on est prêts sur
pratiquement toutes les administrations
où tous les services administratifs
on travaillait vont converger certains
services convergeront au fil du temps en
pendant la période de 2021 pendant
l'année 2020 tient pas forcément au 1er
janvier au jour même j'en veux pour
preuve même la viabilité hivernale de
cet hiver on l'a anticipé pour que les
deux départements est le même traitement
des routes pendant pendant cette période
il y ait un changement de présidence
c'est toujours l'occasion de faire un
bilan
pour brigitte klinkert qui termine son
mandat sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
ces trois années à la tête du conseil
départemental auront permis de
nombreuses avancées la collectivité
européenne bien sûr mais aussi dans le
domaine de la coopération
transfrontalière ou encore celui de
l'aménagement du territoire nous avons
fait un travail énorme je crois pouvoir
le dire avec l'ensemble des collègues
lui mais également avec l'administration
que je tiens à remercier
nous avons avancé dans tous les domaines
dans le domaine des infrastructures pour
être toujours plus en proximité des
collectivités locales que sont les
communes et les communautés de communes
nous avons également beaucoup avancé
dans le domaine de la solidarité pour
être toujours au plus près de nos
concitoyens pas de changement majeur
dans l'organisation du conseil
départemental
si ce n'est que l'ancienne présidente
devient vice présidente
à ce poste elle poursuivra le travail
sur la collectivité qu'elle a de vraies
à créer des collègues ce matin montrent
élue première vice-présidence du conseil
départemental et rémy vite m'a chargé
dans son cadre de la suite de la
construction de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace qui va voir le jour
au 1er janvier prochain et également de
la dimension européenne de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace c'est à
dire de la coopération transfrontalière
c'est pour moi une fierté il ya un
honneur que de pouvoir poursuivre ce
travail pour que nous la collectivité
européenne d'alsace qui va voir le jour
au 1er janvier prochain soit une
réussite